last week  the number of weekly reported deaths  from kobe 19  was the law since march 2020  we have never been in a better position  to end the pandemic  we're not there yet  but  the end is inside a marathon runner does  not stop when the finish line comes into  view  she runs harder  with all the energy she has left  so must we  we can see the finish line  we are in a winning position  but now is the worst time to stop  running  now is the time to run harder  and make sure we cross the line  and reap the rewards of all our hard  work  if we don't take this opportunity now  we run the risk of more variance more  deaths more disruption  and more anxious  uncertainty so let's seize this  opportunity meanwhile  the downward trend  in the global monkey box outbreak is  continuing  but as we scoff at 19  this is not the time to relax or let  down our god  this is the time for all  affected countries and communities to  keep doing what's working